Okay, good.
Oh my gosh, BobbyDev, wow.
Thank you for asking such a wonderful question.
What is that BGM that is in my intro music?
Oh my gosh, that is such a great question.
It's my original BGM composed by Mitsukiyo that a version, a one hour version, will be uploaded to my channel this Friday.
So if you ever want to just listen over and over and over again, you can listen.
And this Friday, it will be uploaded.
Yeah, Mitsukiyo-san.
Yeah.
Anyway, welcome.
Merry Christmas.
Yeah.
Whoa, there's so many gifted.
Whoa, there's so many notifications.
Oh, you guys, my voice is like so dead.
I don't know why.
Great day for a karaoke, probably.
Kara-kitty-kove, thanks for the five gifted.
I'm scrolling!
Thank you for the superchats.
Thank you.
Oh, invisible Moose, thanks for the 20.
Lakery, thanks for the 20.
Cece, thanks for the 10!
It wasn't my birthday today, could I get a happy birthday by any chance?
Oh my gosh, hold on.
I'm gonna grab a cough drop.
I'm also gonna put on some BGM.
Since I'm just talking right now.
Hold on.
I just remembered something.
Oh, BGM.
I'm gonna put on something.
Guys, I'm not prepared at all.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so little prepared.
So little prepared.
Little prepared.
I hope you guys are having a good Christmas Eve or Christmas or whatever whatever that you're doing.
Holiday time.
Day off work.
Days off work.
Hopefully for you, you can just relax and chill and everything.
Hopefully.
Do you guys...I forgot to ask.
Do you guys like my...my...my...my Santa?
Do you guys like it?
I'm so red today.
I'm like a cranberry.
I'm like a full apple.
It's cute?
Yeah?
OK.
I didn't find any BGM, but I'll still sing you Happy Birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mia.
Happy birthday!
Can I get a happy birthday to Kasumi?
I'm trying to surprise her.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Kasumi.
Happy birthday!
Candy canes.
No.
Well, maybe.
Maybe kind of.
Oh my god.
Candy canes are mint flavored.
I'm like a little spiral treat.
Music.
Oh, this one.
I don't know what this sounds like.
What is this?
It's called Christmas.
This works.
Peppermint.
Why is this so...
I don't remember when I ever downloaded this.
In 2020.
Four years ago I've been holding on to this music.
I don't think I ever used it.
Mint karaoke on my birthday.
Too much trouble to request a MGSV style birthday song.
Where are you?
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Oh my god.
A little Christmas music.
Wow, guys.
Welcome to karaoke.
I feel like...
I feel like I've seen a million and one people streaming karaoke today.
Me included.
That's okay.
It's like a concert everywhere you go, right?
It's great.
Now it's a million and two.
Two?
Best karaoke day.
I just... I was like... I don't quite...
I don't quite know what to do, so...
I was like, maybe a karaoke...
I feel like I've been doing quite a lot of karaoke recently, so...
After this one, taking a break.
After this, taking a break of karaoke.
For a bit.
I do need to rest my voice.
Also the concert recently.
Yeah, exactly.
Too much singing.
You guys will be like, oh, it's nothing special.
If I don't put more breaks in.
But you know why also, I pay for the caravan monthly.
So I was like, I gotta do a karaoke at least once a month so that I can...
So that I can not just be not paying for it, you know what I mean?
A while ago, say about one year ago...
When I did the caravan, it would be like...
It was like $50 a month.
In heaven, to use it, because I was in heaven.
But since I'm not in heaven anymore, it's not as expensive.
So I would be like, oh my god, I need to really do karaoke.
Yeah, it was $50 a month to use it.
Mmm...
Merry Christmas, Mint.
Thank you!
Yeah, there was like basically two...
Two, not memberships, two subscriptions you could do.
So...
But now I have it a little bit cheaper.
Yippee!
Yeah.
Business subscription?
Oh, basically.
Basically, basically.
So...
Yeah.
I'm just singing whatever today.
I feel like you guys are probably so sick of Christmas songs.
And...
I don't have to sing any.
Maybe a few.
Just to get into the Christmas mood.
PS, you smell.
I didn't... Well, no, I did read it, but...
Imagine if I didn't read it and all I saw was you smell.
So...
But yeah, Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas, Merry, Merry, Merry Christmas.
You're just now getting into the spirit?
I feel like the Grinch this year.
I don't know, I haven't...
Even though I've been doing stuff, I've been trying to get my own self into the spirit.
I am a spirit.
I think it's because I don't go outside.
I went to... I went to...
The mall the other day.
And I was like, wow, Christmas.
Because I don't really go outside, I never feel like I'm in Christmas time.
I just stay home.
Congrats on 300k!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for a wonderful year, Minto.
Mall still exists?
Yeah!
I had to go to one.
For like a specific store I wanted to go to, sorry.
I'm still eating my cough drop.
Merry Christmas, Happy New Year.
Thanks for the shoes!
Make cafes more comfortable than grass.
So true.
But that's okay.
I hope you guys are feeling a little bit spirited.
To be honest, I actually really dislike Christmas.
I actually don't really like it so much at all, but...
I think when we are able to do...
When we are able to do...
Stuff together makes it better for me.
I have my own reasons, but...
She's going full Grinch.
No!
But, you know.
I'm glad that we can at least do fun stuff and...
It's still fun to...
To do things and do festive things.
It's maybe a fake it till you make it kind of moment.
Where I'm like...
If I do so much festive stuff, I'll feel...
I'll feel the spirit.
Is it another birthday?
Wait, I missed it.
Can I get an early sad happy birthday song for any...
For my attempts at getting happy birthday songs?
Oh no!
Derpy as derp!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Derpy as derp!
Happy birthday!
So many birthdays.
I don't really have a set list or anything.
And I'll sing English and Japanese.
Whatever I feel like.
Okay, I'm sick of this emo music.
I'm sick of the emo music.
Let's sing...
Oh, you know what?
Let's get this one.
This song in.
Let's get this song in.
Since...
Since I'm the Grinch.
Wait, what's the...
Maybe this one.
This will be our test song.
You're a mean one, Mr. Grinch.
You really are a heel.
You're as cuddly as a cactus.
You're as charming as an eel, Mr. Grinch.
You're a bad banana with a greasy black peel.
You're a monster, Mr. Grinch.
Your heart's an empty hole.
Your brain is full of spiders.
You've got garlic in your soul, Mr. Grinch.
I wouldn't touch you with a 39 and a half foot paw.
You're a vile one, Mr. Grinch.
You have termites in your smile.
You have all the tender sweetness of a seasick crocodile, Mr. Grinch.
Given the choice between the two of you, I take the seasick crocodile.
Good thing I'm a garlic girl.
I kind of want the garlic though.
I think...
You're a rotter, Mr. Grinch.
You're the king of sinful thoughts.
Your heart's a dead tomato splat with moldy purple spots, Mr. Grinch.
You're a three-decker sauerkraut and toadstool sandwich with arsenic sauce.
Yummy.
You nauseate me, Mr. Grinch.
With a nausea super nause.
You're a crooked jerky jockey and you drive a crooked horse, Mr. Grinch.
Your soul is an appalling dump.
Heap overflowing with the most disgraceful assortment of rubbish imaginable.
Mangled up, entangled up nuts.
I'm talking about you.
It's a self-insert song.
You're a foul one, Mr. Grinch.
You're a nasty, wasty skunk.
Your heart is full of unwashed socks.
Your soul is full of gunk, Mr. Grinch.
The three words that best describe you are as follows and I quote...
Stink, stank, stunk.
Mr. Grinch.
Oh my god.
That's one thing actually I love about Christmas is...
When the Grinch comes at the Universal Parks.
Because he's so sassy.
I love watching videos of him.
He's so funny.
The Grunk.
Don't say knee surgery.
Don't say that.
That's a brain rot I don't want to ever think about.
He does what?
What do you mean he does what?
He goes to the parks, to the theme parks.
You should check out the Liquid Grinch parody.
I don't think I actually have ever seen that.
What did the Grinch do to deserve this diss track?
He harassed a town and then stole all their presents.
And was really mean for no reason.
He was mean because people had fun.
The singer of that song was the OG voice of Tony the Tiger.
What?
No way.
Thanks for the time gifted.
The Grinch is so relatable.
What?
Stop being Grinch.
Merry Christmas Minto.
Merry Christmas!
God forbid men have hobbies.
Wait, how long has Tony the Tiger... Wait, when was that song released?
Hold on.
I'm going to go back to the emo music so I have nothing else.
Grinch song.
Written and composed in 1966?
But...
How old is Tony the Tiger?
He's a doof?
There's awful fan art of Tony and the Grinch.
I'm not quite surprised about that.
But don't yuck someone's yum.
Tony appeared in 1952?
What?
That's crazy.
I thought... I thought...
What?
No way.
I hope this helps get Otonoke out of my head for a while.
Is that the Dandaran opening?
Recently that song has been so stuck in my head too.
It's so good.
I only know two Creepy Nuts songs, but I like that one.
What was the other one?
I don't remember.
I only know two, but I like that one so much.
It's so good.
It's so, so good.
I don't know that one so well, but I really like the Dandaran opening.
Hmm...
It's so good.
I could not sing it though.
OP to Call of the Night is also great.
I don't know that one.
Call of the Night.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's also Creepy Nuts.
They are popping off.
They're just so dang catchy.
They're so dang catchy.
Are you planning on singing Santa Baby?
Vanilla, do you want me to sing Santa Baby?
Granari, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Santa Baby.
Lock in.
Barry, what are you doing here?
Barry Bug.
What are you doing here?
I only know one song from Hazbin Hotel.
And it's a duet.
I don't think I could sing it.
I don't know if I could.
Tell her to buzz off.
Yeah, buzz off Bug.
Buzz off Bug.
Barry sing it with her.
Barry, do you know?
I do know Hazbin Hotel songs.
I've never watched it either.
Regress, thanks for the ten gifted.
Any chance for Linkin Park?
Now you guys are just saying anything.
There's a chance for anything.
Angry Birds Christmas song.
What?
Lips of an angel.
Stop it.
I can sing Linkin Park.
ViviCorn, thanks for the five gifted.
Sean, thanks for the ten gifted.
Thank you guys so much.
Any chance for Inception sound effects?
How does that even go?
What does that sound like?
What is that?
Was I close?
Hold on.
I don't remember how the...
How the...
Reverb on the sounds, but I'll do my best.
I don't want to be the one the battles always choose Cause inside I realize that I'm the one confused I don't know what's worth fighting for or why I have to scream I don't know why I instigate, say what I don't mean I don't know how I got this way, no it's not alright So I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking the habits And I'm
neglecting my cure I tightly lock the door, I try to catch my breath again I hurt much more than any time No options left again I don't want to be the one the battles always choose Cause inside I realize that I'm the one confused I don't know what's worth fighting for or why I have to scream I don't know why I instigate,
say what I don't mean I don't know how I got this way, it'll never be alright So I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking the habits
I don't know what's worth fighting for or why I have to scream I don't know why I instigate, say what I don't mean I don't know how I got this way, it'll never be alright So I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking
the habits And I...
I said that there will be Christmas songs and whatever It doesn't have to be just Christmas It doesn't have to be just Christmas.
Sometimes we want to sing Linkin Park on Christmas
I'm sorry I could not scream like...
I'm
trying not to kill my voice so so much
Happy Holidays Minto!
Thank you!
Happy Holidays!
Can you sing the Apple Bottom Jeans version?
Oh my gosh, I need to ask Phoebe for that.
It was so funny hearing Apple Bottom Jeans And boots with a fur Thank you for the Aqua Soupa May I request a song if possible?
Always love your version of Hellfire The one from Hunchback of Notre Dame It cheers me up every time I think I can do Hellfire Yeah!
Christmas!
Hellfire!
Hellfire... Here it is I have to like...
I have to like skip the beginning
Hellfire...
I don't know, I feel like I can't...
Is my computer ok?
There we go I feel like I can't sing this song so well at all though I'm like just memeing it Are you sure you like it?
I'm just memeing it usually Hold on
You know I'm so much purer than The common vulgar weak licentious crowd Then tell me Maria Why I see her dancing there Why her smoldering eyes still scorch my soul I feel her, I see her The sun caught in her raven hair Is blazing me out of all control Like fire,
Hellfire This fire in my skin This burning desire Is turning me to sin It's not my fault I'm not to blame It is the wisps I wish to set this flame It's not my fault If in God's plan He made the devil so much stronger than a man Protect me Maria Don't let this siren cast her spell Don't let her fire sear my flesh and bone Destroy all the wisps!
And let them taste the fires of hell!
Or else let's die, I don't want them to be mine.
Minister Frollo, the gypsy has escaped.
She's nowhere in the cathedral.
Who are you?
How did you get into my room?
Guards!
Get this person out of here!
You idiot!
I'll find... I'll find them.
Even if I have to burn down all main cafes!
Hellfire!
Dark fire!
Now wisps, it's your turn.
Choose me or your pyre.
Be mine or you will burn!
God have mercy on you.
God have mercy on me.
But they will be mine or they will burn!
Burn, burn, burn!
Burn baby, burn!
Burn.
Hellfire.
Awesome setlist so far you guys.
For Christmas.
Promise?
Yeah, burn!
I feel called out!
Oh my gosh, burn fire!
Quasimodo predicted this.
What's another Christmas song we could sing?
What's another Christmas song?
Hmm.
September.
No!
I heard of Takagaki Ayahi's cover of All I Want for Christmas.
Wait, no, I don't think I have!
I was, oh my gosh, at the Hololive concert in Atlanta.
I tried, it was either Nerissa or Liz.
I think it was Liz.
Did All I Want for Christmas Is You.
I couldn't remember at all.
Have you guys ever seen the silly...
There was like a TikTok of like a girl...
I have heard that one.
Thank you for always being awesome.
No, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But she's like, oh yeah, I speak English so whenever I go to karaoke in Japan during Christmas time...
They want me to sing All I Want for Christmas Is You so they can do these weird like not...
It's like, I guess it is wotagei, I don't know.
It's like, I only remember like a little bit.
It would be like...
During, when either Liz or Nerissa was singing it, I was like trying to remember it.
I was the only one.
I was the only one doing it.
I was like...
Nobody around me...
Nobody around me knew what I was doing.
I'm afraid I was so obnoxious.
I was true yakai during that concert maybe.
Razer!
Happy Birthday!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Razer Rex.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
It's okay, we were two.
Nobody around me was doing anything.
I was the loudest one in my area.
Rosie, thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
What if I just look up Christmas?
Christmas...
What?
I don't know any of these.
What is this?
Baby, please come home.
What is that one?
Christmas time?
Oh my god, Charlie Brown.
Christmas time is here.
Do I know that one?
Hippopotamus song again?
I like that song.
Oh wait, someone asked for Santa Baby, right?
Is this the one?
Santa baby, just slip a sable under the tree for me.
Been an awful good girl, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa baby, a 54 convertible too, light blue.
I'll wait up for you dear, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Think of all the fun I've missed, think of all the fellas that I haven't kissed.
Next year I could be just as good, if you check off my Christmas list.
Santa baby, I want a yacht and really that's not a lot.
Been an angel all year, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa honey, one little thing I really need, the D to a platinum mine.
Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa cutie, fill my stocking with the duplex and checks.
Sign the X on the line, Santa cutie, and hurry down the chimney tonight.
Come and trim my Christmas tree, with some decorations bought at Tiffany's.
I really do believe in you, let's see if you believe in me.
Santa baby, forgot to mention one little thing, a ring.
I don't mean on your phone, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry...tonight.
Fine!
Are you happy now?
Are you happy?
Glad I got that out of the way.
Wishing you butaro...butaro...butaro and pies a merry Christmas.
Thank you!
They are pregnant now.
Meep!
Thank you for the hakusupa, meep!
Best I got is a ring camera.
Wow, gato!
Thank you for the hakusupa, thank you!
Minto baby got me acting unwise.
Stop it!
Control yourself!
Down!
Sprite!
Love deterrents, could be considered Santa or Christmas.
I guess it could be.
Maybe not love deterrents, let's do another one.
Let's do instead the other song.
I guess it could be because in Peace Walker they talk about...they talk about...they talk about Santa.
I can't think of anything right now.
There we go.
OK.
OK, OK, OK.
Hold on.
Let me double check this.
I think this is good, but let me double check it.
OK.
I might have to adjust the audio while I go.
Once new, old and shattered now.
Love can kill, love will die.
Give me wings to fly.
Fleeing this world so cold.
I just wonder why.
Cold as the dark.
Now my words are frosted with every breath.
Still the hate burns wild.
Growing inside this heart.
When the wind changes course.
When the stars align.
I will reach out to you.
And leave this all behind.
When heavens divide.
I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach?
As the end draws near.
When heavens divide.
Time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When heavens divide.
I'll dive into the fire.
Spilling the blood of my desire.
The very last time my name is scorched into the sky.
When heavens divide.
I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach?
As the end draws near.
When heavens divide.
Time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When heavens divide.
Yay!
Heavens divide!
Christmas!
Yay!
Sound Christmas.
I'm trying to think.
I mean, I guess it's fine if I sing things I sang last time.
It's fine if I sing whatever I want.
Sing whatever I want.
Long time lurker whisperer.
Last year's songs really got me in the Christmas spirit.
I know you're feeling grinchy but your streams grew my heart three whole sizes.
Thank you!
Merry Christmas!
Have you listened to Mistress for Christmas by AC?
Wait, no.
I don't think I know that one.
Maybe I do, but I'm not sure.
If Die Hard is a Christmas movie, that's a Christmas song.
So true!
So true.
Sorry.
I'm trying to think.
No, I'm not going to do break stuff tonight, you guys.
My voice, I don't think, can handle it.
I did break stuff literally this month.
Give me a break stuff.
Heaven's Divide is my most favorite MGS song.
I don't know, I always switch between...
Smash Boo, thanks for the 10 gifted.
I was going to say me too, but also...
Twice this month.
Give me a break.
Mellow soft break stuff.
I don't think I can.
I don't think it's in me.
When break stuff happens...
I become... I turn red.
I see red, you know?
I see red.
I can't, it just comes out.
Merry Chrysler, Merry Chrysler!
Merry Chrysler.
Are Doki songs from the concert still stuck in your head?
Sing them now.
I don't think I... wait.
Oh Panda, thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I possibly be?
Well there's a principle of nature That almost every creature knows Called survival of the fittest And check it, this is how it goes The animal that wins gotta scratch and fight and claw and bite and punch And the animal that doesn't, well the animal that doesn't Wines up someone else's lunch I don't know this song.
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally How bad can I be?
I'm just following my destiny How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
Well there's a principle in business That everybody knows the sound It says the people with the money Make this ever-loving world go round So I'm bigger in my company, I'm bigger in my factory I'm bigger in my corporate side Everybody out there, you take care of yours and me I'll take care of mine,
mine, mine, mine, mine Shake that bottom line Smoke Schlappity schlap Complaining all you want is never ever ever gonna stop Come on, how bad can I possibly How bad can I be?
I'm just building the economy How bad can I be?
Just look at me petting this puppy How bad can I be?
How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
Let's see How bad can I be?
All the customers are buying How bad can I be?
And the money is multiplying How bad can I be?
And the PR people are lying How bad
can I be?
Who cares if a few trees are dying How bad can I be?
This is all so gratifying How bad
This song is so dumb
Oh my god
Do I have to put that on my set list?
You know what, it's fine How bad can I be?
My voice is a little squeakerton today, I'm sorry I'm so squeaky today I sound like Pies when she gets mad at me Well not mad at me, she just comes up to me and she's always
Is that mint before a merch drop?
I have had one merch drop Mito-chan that wasn't very green vtuber coded of you, I know, I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry Pies is a squeaker?
Oh my god, the squeakiest She is so squeaky Hey Mito can we get a Godzilla sound?
My birthday was on the 19th but work was on so I couldn't get you to stream No!
Any chance I can get a brief song so I can hear your Disney song of choice?
Grooton!
Of course!
Also Desert Drisky, thank you!
I love the outfit, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Grooton!
I don't know what to...wait Name a Disney song.
I'll sing the first one I see, maybe Name a Disney song I don't know my favorite one Serenra!
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you Circle of Life?
No way!
It's so funny you would bring up the Lion King
Please be on here!
No!
I don't think it's on here!
Please
Hold on, let me check if this is OK
I don't know the words at all to this I don't know anything of this song OK everybody, this is from the new Mufasa movie It's called
I Always Wanted a Brother I'm
crying I
have not stopped singing Thank you for another 50!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it!
OK hold on, let me get the lyrics I always wanted a brother
I'm sorry, I don't know how this song goes at all except the chorus
Disney, you put up the instrumental yourself so don't get mad at me, OK?
If this is what claims the video I might lose it When does it come in?
When I am king, no other animal will break my stride, break my stride And my brother, my brother When I'm king, you'll always take my side, yeah right I'm totally improvising this, I don't know if you can tell When I'm king, when you are king, no other animal will break our pride,
break our pride And my brother, my brother Our pray may run away, but they can't hide Watch her hide, let's go!
Oh, let's go!
Hey, did your mama say you could be out this late?
OK, she didn't say, either way Hey, did your father say you could be out this far?
OK, we're on our way, on our way Hey, did your mama say you could be out...
It's coming, you guys.
I see it in the lyrics
Make a wish on a brightest star, and I say, I always...
Please explain the funny
OK OK
It started in October When I watched the trailer for the Mufasa movie And there was a line in it that just got me Because it was just so awkward
And...
It's like, I always wanted a brother And then for some reason, oh gosh, now I'm explaining the joke And people are gonna be like, this is not funny at all
And then they said it again, they're like, I always wanted a brother Oh my god, I posted it on Twitter And then literally, like, three nights ago Like, just very recently Again, this started in October and it's been stuck in my head since then Like, three days ago I discovered that the awkward line that they used in the trailer was actually part of this stupid song And it's just the way that they say,
I always wanted a brother I always wanted a brother I can't stop saying it
I can't stop saying it Oh, it's so terrible Oh, it's so terrible, it sounds so bad
Okay, I got it out of my system Okay My tears, my shirt is wet because I've been wiping my tears I always wanted a brother Just look it up Just listen to it Obviously I can't or Disney will strike me down I always wanted a brother I always wanted a brother I always wanted a brother
I can't stop saying it Where are my background singers at?
Wait, wasn't that a Christmas song?
The background singer song?
Wait, where are my backup singers at?
What was she saying?
Oh, this Christmas!
Yeah Do I know this song?
Let's try it
Okay, I'm cool, I'm calm.
I'm cool as a cucumber I'm cool as a cucumber
Hang all the mistletoe I'm gonna get to know you better This Christmas I need you to move the cue cards faster, honey!
I can't read!
This Christmas Where's my backup singers at?
I can't read the cue cards!
Through the night Faster, faster, faster!
And this Christmas Will be a very special Christmas For me Where are my backup singers at?
Presents and cards are here My world is filled with cheering you This Christmas And as I look around Your eyes are shining down on me This Christmas Fireside is blazing bright We're caroling through the night And this Christmas Christmas will be a very special Christmas for me.
Yeah!
The
fireside is blazing bright.
We're caroling through the night.
And this is the second one.
I had something stuck in my throat.
A very special Christmas for me.
Because
I'm here.
Shake a hand for our singers.
Where's your brother?
Oh, she's saying boo.
Goodness gracious.
There were actually no backup singers in that.
I'm really upset about it.
Thank you for the five gifted.
My voice is so bad today.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm always blown away by your singing voice.
Liquid, don't say that.
I literally... I flopped.
My voice is like...
I can't... Oh gosh.
When I'm in Japan, I'm not gonna talk to anybody.
I'm just gonna be like... I'm gonna be so silent.
Hopefully my voice will recover.
Hopefully.
Hopefully, hopefully.
What's a song that I can actually sing?
Morita!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Merry Christmas, Aki!
Thank you!
Merry Christmas!
I appreciate it.
Even when you're not in tip-top shape, we're still having fun.
Yeah, we're here for fun.
We're here for fun.
No matter how your voice comes out, it's perfect.
Thank you!
Okay, we were supposed to sing a Disney song.
You guys said a bunch and I got distracted by the Lion King.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm gonna sing a real... Hold on.
Beauty and the Beast.
Actually...
I do have a favorite Beauty and the Beast song.
I wonder if I can sing it though.
I wonder if I can sing it though with my voice.
I'll try.
I'll be scuffed.
So sorry.
I can't... I've been muting and clearing my throat so bad.
Oh wait, there is a Beauty and the Beast song too.
That's another... That's actually a Christmas song.
I was the one who had it all I was the master of my fate I never needed anybody in my life I learned the truth too late I'll never shake away the pain I close my eyes but she's still there I let her steal into my melancholy heart It's more than I can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me, Even as she runs away.
She will still torment me, Calm me, hurt me, move me, come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower, Waning by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in, And be with me forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love, I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach, She's never out of sight.
Now I know she'll never leave me, Even as she fades from view.
She will still inspire me, Be a part of everything I do.
Wasting in my lonely tower, Waning by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in, And as the long, long nights begin, I'll think of all that might have been, Waiting here for...
Oh my goodness.
I think I might have to go get a... what's it called?
Oh my gosh, I forgot to update the setlist.
Just ignore the last couple of songs.
I might have to go grab a... what's it called?
I had a cough drop, but I think I'm gonna have to take some other stuff.
I'm so phlegmy, that's the issue.
I'm so phlegmy.
I'm in awe, thank you!
Thank you.
I'm gonna put it in my tea.
Some stuff in my tea that should help.
Some menthol-y stuff.
The Chinese medicine, yeah!
I need it.
I don't have it in here, I gotta leave it in my kitchen.
Okay, hold on.
Give me one second.
I'm so sorry.
Listen to the Christmas music.
I'm back.
I'm back with my medicine.
What's a Christmas song?
Chestnuts roasting.
That is a Christmas song.
I'm gonna do this one other Beauty and the Beast song, since I thought of it earlier.
Joy, thank you for the pink!
I think this is... wait, I need... wait.
There's something sweet and almost kind.
But he was mean and he was coarse and unrefined.
And now he's dear and so unsure.
I wonder why I didn't see it there before.
Wait, is there no Beast part?
Wait, there's no extra voice that can do the Beast.
I have to sing the Beast!
Myself?
Okay, here we go.
She glanced this way.
I thought I saw.
And when we touched, she didn't shudder at my paw.
No, it can't be.
I'll just ignore.
But then she's never looked at me this way before.
Glory!
Who'd have ever thought that this could be?
True, that he's no Prince Charming.
But there's something in him that I simply didn't see.
Well, who'd have thought?
Well, bless my soul.
Well, who'd have known?
Well, who indeed?
And who'd have guessed?
They'd come together on their own.
It's so peculiar.
Wait and see.
A few days more.
There may be something there that wasn't there before.
You know, perhaps there's something there that wasn't there before.
What is it?
Something there that wasn't there before.
I'll tell you when you're older, Chip.
That was something there from Beauty and the Beast.
The paw line when she didn't shudder at my paw is so funny.
Mama, what's a furry?
Once upon a December.
Oh yeah, we'll do that one too.
I just woke up and got jumpscared by my R on your thumbnail.
My!
Thank you!
My R tag is like broken for me and I have that in my bookmarks.
I sometimes bookmark art that I want to use for thumbnails.
But I also bookmark a lot of other things too and I forget to scroll through.
So I was scrolling because I can't see it through my R tag right now.
And I saw it from so long ago and I was like, yeah!
Once upon a December.
Someone holds me safe and warm Horses dance through a silver storm Figures dancing gracefully Across my memory
Someone holds me safe and warm Horses prance through a silver storm Figures dancing gracefully Across my memory Far away, long ago Glowing dim as an ember Things my heart used to know Things it yearns to remember And a song someone sings
That song's hard.
That song's hard to sing.
Thank you.
Thanks for singing my favorite song from my favorite movie, Rendition of the Beautiful.
Thank you!
I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Appreciate it.
Thank you guys for all the donos.
Thank you for all the memberships, all the donated memberships, or gifted memberships.
I really appreciate it.
If you're, if by chance you're taking requests, I'd love to hear, perfect by smashing pumpkins.
I don't know if I know it.
Hold on, let me see.
Perfect by smashing pumpkin.
Hold on, I'm gonna listen to it.
Oh, let me listen to it.
I'm listening, I'm listening.
Oh, I do know this song, but I don't know if I know it well enough to sing it.
I'm sorry, I don't know.
Maybe I'll, let me add it to my list.
Hold on.
I've been, Songs to Learn.
I have a, I have a, I have my own like private discord, like personal, you know, just for like notes and stuff for myself.
And I, I have a, I have now a channel called Songs to Learn.
So, I add things on there when you guys request it and I don't know it.
So that I can go back and be like, oh, because I feel like I sing so many of the same songs sometimes.
Is it a long list?
Well, I only did it recently.
So, I only started it recently.
So it's kind of a, not the longest list.
Oh my gosh, I want to sing this song because I want to sing it.
I thought of it the other night and I was like, oh wait, I like this song.
It's not a Christmas song, so, but that's okay.
I've never sung this song, I think, before in karaoke, so that's good.
I don't know if it's worth it anymore.
My arms, I just wanted to hold you in my arms,
all the souls that would die just to feel alive.
But I'll never let you go if you promise not to fade away, never.
Our
hopes and expectations, black holes and revelations.
Our hopes and expectations,
black holes and revelations.
Oh, the ship is taking me far away.
Merry Christmas, thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
Oh, now I'm scrolling up, I think I saw some more, but they disappeared.
Where'd they go?
No, oh no, no.
Flora, Merry Christmas.
It was amazing, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas, Midtime Lurker, but I always love hearing your singing.
Thank you, Blaster.
Could we get a little dive with a smile as a treat?
I can try.
Don't be alarmed, but I think I saw a suspicious-looking gift box moving by itself outside your house.
It had legs under it.
It's crazy that they wrote this song and Snow Halation.
Wait, what?
Oh, shut up.
I was like, what are you talking about?
Merry Christmas, Minto and the Wiz.
Thank you, before I go...
But I have to go, but before that, I just want to thank you for everything and help you enjoy your trip.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Dive with a smile.
Whose part should I be?
Maybe I'll do... I'll do Bruno when he's lead and I'll do Lady Gaga when she's lead.
So strict!
Thanks for the 10k!
I survived, I realized.
Wherever you go, though, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promised tomorrow.
So I'mma love you every night like it's the last night, like it's the last night.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through, I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And dive with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through, I'd want to hold you just for a while.
Oh my god, sudden Bruno Mars.
Lost, lost in the words that we scream.
I don't even want to do this anymore.
Cause you already know what you mean to me.
And I'm lost, the only one worth fighting for.
Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promised tomorrow.
So I'mma love you every night like it's the last night, like it's the last night.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through, I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And dive with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Right next to you.
Next to you.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through, I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And dive with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
I'd want to be next to you.
Yeah!
That was...
Dive with a smile.
Pegasus, thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh my goodness.
Merry Christmas Minto, you rock!
You rock!
Sleepy Otter, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Could you please sing Bad Applebottom Jeans?
Wait, how is there a Bad Applebottom?
Also take Snow Halation by Shawty's Like a Melody.
I don't even know that one.
Wait.
Bad...
How do I...
Applebottom jeans, white boots with the fur, the whole club is looking at her.
I don't know the rest of the song.
It's fine on the outside.
Maybe, I can sing that one.
Marissa, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Erin Copper, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Applebottom jeans, white boots with the fur, Shawty got the whole club looking at her.
Is that how it goes?
I don't know one.
I don't know that one.
My happy arrived in time for Christmas!
I'm glad I made it!
There goes Stalker.
Toho, hi Jack.
What kind of Toho song?
Toho, Toho, I wonder.
Wouldn't it be crazy if Carophone had Bad Apple?
Oh, I'm just getting apples.
What do elves post on social media?
Elfies.
Stop.
Stop it, Eric.
Throwing in my shot for Twilight.
I love Twilight.
I don't know if I can sing it today though, Karateko.
I think my voice is not up to speed.
Let me see.
I wonder if it has this.
That would be so funny.
No, but I can still sing it.
I'll try.
Wait, no.
No, this isn't the song that was Applebottom Jeans.
I don't think.
NobGoblin, thanks for the 5 gifters!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Whatever, I can just do it properly.
I'll just do it properly.
Annihilation
I'm going to sing a song called, I'm going to run to the future right
now.
I want to hold you.
Wherever you are, wherever you are.
Come on, before I know it.
I've grown too big.
It's like I'm only dreaming.
It's painful.
I want to be your lover.
I'm confused by your kind eyes.
I don't like it.
I'm going to give you all my love.
Give it to me, please.
I'm going to put my name on the pain of delivering.
No hurry shot.
Until the feelings overlap,
I don't wait.
It's frustrating, but it's okay to love.
Don't hesitate in the heat.
Yeah!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I've sung it properly for the first time in a long time.
I always end up singing the Flintstones.
Merry Christmas!
Advocate!
Thank you for the Hakusuba!
Merry Christmas!
Nerdy Laundry, thank you so much for the tangata!
Thank you!
Flintstones, meet the Flintstones.
They're your modern stone age family.
From the town of Bedrock.
Happy Holidays everyone.
Happy Holidays!
Thank you Jody!
Thank you for the tonigata!
Thank you!
It's a Christmas miracle.
Was that not the official lyrics?
It should be, right?
It's been like poison in my brain to do the Flintstones version.
Vector-san, thank you for the tonigata!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
This Christmas...
I did do this Christmas earlier.
But I kind of messed it up.
I don't want to do it again.
I'm embarrassed.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Damnit!
Thank you for the ten gifted.
Oh my goodness, goodness, goodness.
Thank you, thank you guys.
Thank you.
No backup singers.
Ah, there are no backup singers.
Sad.
Need to get back to family.
But Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas Nora!
Thanks for hanging out!
Eternal snow?
Yeah, we can do that one.
Eto!
Thanks for the ten gifted.
You missed my super chat request.
Still good to hear snow-holation by the way.
Oh, sorry!
It's like hard to see sometimes.
I'm sorry!
What was it?
You can say it in chat.
I still read the chat, you know, for suggestions too.
Some of my friends got forced to stop lifting by security when Phoebe was singing that's a phantom thief's revenge even though the rules were lift at your own risk.
Unfortunately, well, it is your own risk.
Unfortunately, you know, security doesn't always align with our beliefs.
John, thank you for the fifty gifted!
Thank you!
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted!
Kairu, welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
You read chat?
No, I never read chat.
A super chat is asking for another Vocaloid winter song.
Oh, Snowman by HALO-C.
I don't know, I don't think I know that one.
I can try, oh gosh, I don't want to sing, I'm going to be in, what's the word?
In Aura's Christmas, in her Christmas, she has a big Christmas concert.
And I don't want to sing the one I sang in that.
Another Christmas Vocaloid.
Don't ever read my chat asking for Lips of an Angel again.
I don't want to sing Lips of an Angel!
I don't want to sing it today!
When the first love ends?
That's the one I was thinking of.
So let me do Eternal Snow first and then I'll do...
What's the Japanese?
There, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, okay, let me check this real quick.
I hope it's not so crunchy.
Okay, this sounds fun.
Oh
Tears won't stop.
I wish I didn't know about you.
How long will I keep thinking about you?
I wonder if it's true.
The sigh clouded the window glass.
With a candle that lights up my shaking heart, I wonder if I can melt it now.
Hold me tight.
Hold me strong enough to break.
Even if I stumble, I hope it won't be cold.
I miss you.
Every time I think of you.
This scarf that I can't knit.
I'll hold it alone tonight.
If there is snow that falls forever, this feeling that continues with you.
I wonder if I can hide this feeling.
Hold me tight.
If it's a feeling like this, I didn't want to know the feeling of falling in love with someone.
I didn't want to know.
I love you.
I want to shout to the winter sky that rises in my heart.
I want to see you right now.
She loves us.
I don't get to twist it now, okay?
Also...
Oh no, I lost.
I'm trying to click it.
Oh gosh.
Eternal snow made me cry my eyes out back in high school and changed the trajectory of my life forever.
Oh my gosh.
I kind of have a similar story though.
Because...
A long time ago...
One of the bodies I frequently possessed would get sick very often.
And like...
They like...
Felt very connected.
What's the main character's name?
Mitsuki, I think.
They felt so connected to her.
They were just like, oh my god, she's so much like me.
I'm dying.
She's dying.
So...
Hopefully, that body I possess is okay.
Mitsuki's story was so inspirational.
I know!
We're all dying.
Technically.
Well, I'm already dead.
If you're alive, you're technically dying.
Let's see...
This song.
Let me check it.
Let me check it, let me check it, let me check it, check it, check it.
This should be good.
This was...
Miku's song.
Nah, I'd leave.
Ah...
It's like a drama.
It's like a love story.
As if I had foreseen it, the bell of gratitude rang.
The cold winter wind almost woke me up.
I breathed out and rubbed my hands.
The city was illuminated.
I cast a spell.
Every time, the streetlights were bare.
I couldn't say it no matter what.
I suppressed my feelings.
I hadn't made up my mind.
If
I stop, I'll remember.
So, thank you.
Goodbye.
I won't cry.
That's what I thought.
It's like a dream.
That's how I felt.
When I touched it, it melted and disappeared.
The two of us, It's like we're having fun.
Look, it's the first snow.
I wanted to be like that with you.
I made a hand-knit scarf for the first time.
I don't know why I gave it to you.
I'm a coward.
I was just afraid.
If it's a memory,
I'll cry.
I
should have known Thank you.
The train is coming.
It hurts me now.
I want to be with you.
How much do I have
to wish?
I know that.
You're being nice to me.
So let go of my hand.
I'm glad I met you.
I like you.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
I can't say a word.
Just for now.
Courage to me.
Hey, I'm just saying.
I'm sorry.
I don't remember how far I got.
It's okay to cry just for now.
I don't need words anymore.
Please hold me tight.
What kind of me is there now?
What kind of you is there now?
Sorry, I forgot that part.
Oops.
Oh my goodness.
I missed out on some...
Sorry, some donuts too.
Thank you for the Akadono.
I hope you have a happy holiday.
You too.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
A cracked apple is on your list.
A cracked apple.
Wait, hold on.
That was...
The first...
When the first love ends.
You know I may not get what I want for Christmas.
But I won't give up.
Perseverance.
Run it from Sonic Movie 3.
I haven't even seen Sonic 3, Jacob.
I haven't even seen it.
It's possible to do Last Christmas.
My last attempt to request goodbye days.
Goodbye days like...
If P2W even works.
Oh my god, stop.
Don't act like that.
Don't be like that.
I'm sorry if I miss it.
I'm sorry.
I don't...
Please don't guilt me if I miss something.
It makes me so sad.
Especially if you're spending so much money.
And I don't know the song.
I'm gonna feel so bad, you know.
It's best to, you know, not donate song requests.
Because, you know...
I might not always know the song.
And then you'll be like, oh, I spent the money.
I sent the money, and she doesn't know the song.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
But I don't... I only know the...
Goodbye days...
Also, it helps to send...
This is for everybody too.
It helps to also send who the artist is.
Because sometimes there are lots of songs that are the same...
The same title, you know what I mean?
So...
Just in general, I think that's a...
If you're...
Say, if you're even with another streamer who's taking song requests too.
Then...
Then you can...
Then they'll know exactly what it is.
It doesn't need to be in Kyrofun.
It doesn't.
No, no, no.
So yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
Dogdog, thank you for the hakusuba!
There's now a cream bowl here!
I won't really celebrate, but I wanted to give you a gift.
Thank you!
Thank you for the hakusuba!
Cold December night.
Michael... I don't know that... Cold December night.
I don't think I know that one.
Thank you for the hakusuba!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oomph and I figured out you can mix to Last Christmas.
Oh my gosh.
Well, that's the one by Wham, right?
Hold on.
Someone requested something earlier.
Oh gosh, what was it?
I mean, there's been so many requests.
There's been so many requests.
What was it?
Oh, I know there was Chestnuts.
Can you sing this?
Oops, it must have gotten deleted.
Snowman by Sia.
Sia has a snow song?
Thank you for the five gifts at Shadow Cross!
Sing the minky, minky, minky, minky, minky.
There was something I wanted to sing.
Chestnuts roasting on an open fire.
I can't ever sing that song.
That guy does it the best way.
What was it?
This one.
Here we go.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Can you mix here?
One's bitten and twice shy.
I keep my distance, but you still catch my eye.
Tell me, baby, do you recognize me?
Well, it's been a year, it doesn't surprise me.
I wrapped it up and sent it with a note saying, I love you, I meant it.
Now I know what a fool I've been.
But if you kiss me now, I know you'd pull me again.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
And your soul of ice, my God, I thought you were someone to rely on.
Me, I guess I was a shoulder to cry on.
Face on a lover with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, but you tore me apart.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
But the very next day, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Face on a lover with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, but you tore me apart.
This year, to save me from
tears, I'll give it to someone special.
I already typed it, my bad.
I like them both.
Honestly.
I always try to get your stream even if I'm meaning on the background.
Thank you, Azura!
Thank you!
Can you do Angelic Angel?
You know, I'm not good at that song.
If this will be the last karaoke for a minute, can we get one more Snake Eater for the road?
Well, it's definitely gonna be the last one this year.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
Okay, let me do some Christmas songs.
Ding, fries are done.
Caesar, how old are you?
How old are you?
Meowie, Chrysler, Minto, can you sing Collective Christmas?
All I want for Christmas is collective consciousness.
What is that?
What are you talking about?
No New Year karaoke?
I won't be here.
Wait, this is a Frank Sinatra version?
Let's try it.
My ears!
You better watch out, you better not cry.
You better not pout, I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He's making a list and checking it twice.
He's gonna find out who's naughty and nice.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He sees you when you're sleeping.
He knows when you're awake.
He knows if you've been bad or good.
So be good boy, couldn't you say?
Oh, you better not want, oh, you better not cry.
You better not pout, I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
Say, you better watch out, you better not cry.
You better not pout, I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He's making a list, he's checking it twice.
He's gonna find out who's naughty and nice.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He sees you when you're sleeping.
He knows when you're awake.
He knows if you've been bad or good.
So be good boy, couldn't you say?
Oh, you better watch out, you better not cry.
You better not pout, I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
Sorry, I was completely sight reading that.
I didn't know that version at all.
Oh my god.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
Tonight, Noel Rad is tracking him right now.
You better watch out, you better watch out.
Thank you for the five gift, I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
You better watch out, you better watch out.
It's a pretty tough year for me, but I'm glad you came back from the afterlife to haunt us again.
Thank you officer.
Thank you for all that you do.
Thank you so much, I appreciate it.
Idolize!
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you.
You better watch out, you better watch out.
Thank you for the 15 gifts.
Can you sing us the most wonderful time of the year by Andy Williams?
It's my favorite Christmas song.
I can try!
Andy Williams, thank you.
I always love the super jazzy covers of Christmas classics.
Thank you!
I do too, they are so fun to sing too.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
It's the hap-happiest season of all.
With those holiday greetings and gay happy meetings when friends come to call.
There'll be parties for hosting, marshmallows for toasting, and caroling out in the snow.
There'll be scary ghost stories and tales of the glories of Christmases long, long ago.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
There'll be much mistletoeing and hearts will be glowing when loved ones are near.
There'll be parties for hosting, marshmallows for toasting, and caroling out in the snow.
There'll be scary ghost stories and tales of the glories of Christmases long, long ago.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
There'll be much mistletoeing and hearts will be glowing when loved ones are near.
It's the most wonderful time.
Oh, the most wonderful time of the year.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Zephy, thank you for the pick!
Supporting StinkyRanky.
I appreciate it.
Sprite, why did you guys keep saying Sprite Cranberry?
What does this song have to do with the Sprite Cranberry?
UpsideDownLappy, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you, thank you.
What does this have to do with the Sprite Cranberry anyway?
Want one?
I can't drink soda.
MerCrimbusReTuber, MerCrimbusJerry, thanks for the gift!
Ask LeBron James.
I thought you know this one, but could you add Snoopy's Christmas to your list for next year?
I tagged you with David K's Animal Megatron Christmas Carol.
Merry Crimbo, Minky.
I will check it after stream.
Why?
I'm not gonna remember next year.
Cornelius, welcome to membership.
No, I'm just kidding.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much!
CV, thanks for 5 bots.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I don't get it.
Can you do I Want a Hippopotamus for Christmas?
I'd like to see Gremlin Mint though.
Otherwise, I saw Mommy kissing Santa Claus.
I can do a Hippopotamus.
I already sang Santa, baby.
It's one embarrassing song enough.
Have a happy... Almost Christmas means it wasn't Christmas.
No particular request from you.
Thanks so much!
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
You guys are so... So help you guys, please.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas Only a hippopotamus will do I don't want a doll, no dinky tinker toy I want a hippopotamus to play with and enjoy I want a hippopotamus for Christmas I don't think Santa Claus will mind, do you?
He won't have to use our dirty chimney blue Just bring him through the front door, it's the easy thing to do I can see me now on Christmas morning Creeping down the stairs Oh, what joy and what surprise When I open up my eyes to see a hippo hero standing there I want a hippopotamus for Christmas Only a hippopotamus will do No crocodiles or rhinoceroses I only like hippopotamuses And hippopotamuses like me too
Mom says the hippo would eat me up within Teacher says a hippo is a vegetarian
Bite of 87 There's lots of room for him in our two-car garage I feed him there and wash him there and give him a massage.
I can see me now on Christmas morning, creeping down the stairs.
Oh, what joy and what surprise when I open up my eyes.
See a hippo hero standing there.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Only a hippopotamus will do.
No crocodiles or rhinoceroses.
I only like hippopotamuses.
And hippopotamuses like me too.
How does he know that hippopotamuses like him?
How does he know?
Thanks for the hippo.
Akira, welcome.
Welcome to my bushes.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hold on.
I thought I saw something.
Call me a hippo because I like Minto.
Stop.
The teacher is right.
Hippopotamus will end this girl's career.
She will never work in this town again.
I just don't understand this song.
I don't understand this song to be honest.
A hippo is an allegory for something.
I don't know.
Truly, I have no idea.
There was one song.
What was it?
Oh, someone asked for White Christmas.
I can sing that one.
Is it snowing where you guys are?
Are you having a White Christmas?
Only rain.
No, it snowed all day yesterday.
I used to know Where the treetops glisten And children listen To hear sleigh bells in the snow
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas, with every Christmas card I write.
May your days be merry and bright, and may all your Christmases be white.
Just turn that A.C.
down.
Make it so cold.
Just like the ones I used to know, where the treetops glisten and children listen.
And if you don't have snow, make the snow asbestos.
Perfect.
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas, with every Christmas card I write.
May your days be merry and bright,
and may all your Christmases be white.
Just turn that A.C.
down.
Make it so cold.
No, it wasn't actually true.
What?
Yeah.
It wasn't real.
Someone's dandruff.
What was it?
I don't remember.
I don't remember what it was.
So was the Tin Man's makeup not deadly?
Actually, that is also... So, to say that good things happen...
Hold on, how do I say?
The amount of bad things that happen on the Wizard of Oz set has been greatly dramatized and exaggerated for that movie.
I think because of just surrounding things, especially with Judy Garland and everything like that.
I believe the first... There was two Tin Man's actually.
I believe it was the first Tin Man.
His makeup was deadly.
But the second Tin Man... And he had a bad allergic reaction.
But he was fine.
There were rumors that he passed away because of the makeup.
But that's not the case.
So...
He was allergic, but it's not bad for most people.
He was dead, but fine.
No, he didn't die!
He didn't die.
They said that he died, but he didn't.
Oh!
Santa!
Santa's here!
Santa, thank you for the five gifted!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he died, but he got better.
Santa, Santa, Santa, Santa, am I on the good list?
Check Mint Phantom.
It might be under Minky.
Am I on the good list or the naughty list?
I think I'm on the good list.
Hold on.
Santa...
I'm on the freaky list.
Nice!
I'm on the nice list!
Oh my god!
Hold on.
Yeah!
It's my trophy.
It's like when someone hangs up their diploma.
Yay!
Wow, you didn't even like it.
I was so excited.
Sorry Santa.
Can we double check that?
No!
It's correct.
It came from Old Santa Nick.
The big man himself.
I'm nice!
I don't agree.
What do you mean you don't agree?
Is it because I haunted you?
What did you bribe Santa for this?
No!
I didn't do anything!
I just asked right here, right now.
You all saw it.
Yeah!
Nice.
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
No, not stage.
Not rigged.
Merry Christmas!
Let's do one last song you guys.
Maybe one last song.
And then I'll leave you to guys.
I'll have sweet Christmas dreams and wake up with many presents under your tree.
What is your wish for...
I don't know if I should tell you that, Kewpie.
Santa's being nice to his elves.
People forget that Scarecrow carries a revolver.
If you're still taking requests, evening in December.
Evening in December.
Who's that by?
I don't know if I know that one.
We gotta make the last song a good one.
Oh, I don't even see it on my thing.
Uncensored version of Mr. Grinch?
There's an uncensored version?
Snake Eater for the ending?
Okay, I'll do two more then.
Because I see a bunch of people asking for...
I don't know why you guys want me to sing this one so much, but I'll sing it.
Okay, I'll do two more.
In
my mind.
No, I will sing this, don't worry.
Hold on, I'm gonna sing Snake Eater first.
Sorry for the bait.
Okay, here we go.
What a thrill I'm searching and I'm melting to you What a fear in my heart But you're so, so free I'd give my life Not for all
this Snake Eater In my time There'll be no one else Crime, it's the way I fly to you Snake Eater I'm still in a dream Snake Eater
Someday you'll go through the rain Someday you'll feed on a tree frog It's ordeal, the trial to survive For the day we see new light I'd give my life
But my time There'll be no one else Crime, it's the way I fly to you Snake Eater I'm still in a dream Snake Eater
Oh shit I always do this I always pick the wrong version Thank you so much for the 50 gifts And, oh gosh And Bively, thank you so much for the 50 gifts
You're pretty good
Snake Eater In my time There'll be...
It just cut off An actual Dimetrodon Thank you!
Thank you for the hot costume part.
Thank you, I appreciate it so much
Feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad
Feliz Navidad
Feliz Navidad Prospero ao y felicidad I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I want to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas.
I want to wish you a minky Christmas.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
Apple bottom jeans.
And boots with the fur.
Shawnee got the whole club.
Looking at her.
She had the bottom jeans.
Boots with the fur.
Got the whole club.
Wish you a Merry Christmas.
Thank
you for the karaoke.
I don't see you guys.
Well, I know it's Christmas for some people.
It's really Christmas Eve for me.
But I think it's more fun to celebrate Christmas on Christmas Eve.
Minky Christmas.
Merry Christmas.
Happy Holidays everybody.
Happy Holidays.
Haunt me tomorrow.
Morning 9am.
I make Danish Kringle pastry.
I'll be there.
Haunting you.
Maximo.
Thank you for the help.
I've been watching YouTube since COVID and never really got the whole issue thing.
After watching your streams, clips of you in the community for a while now.
And don't say I didn't help.
Thank you.
Merry Christmas.
Maximino.
I'm so sorry.
I only said Maximo.
Maximomo.
Otomito.
I'm so late.
Merry Christmas.
Merry Minky Christmas.
Merry Minky Minky.
Minky Minky Minky.
Thank you everybody.
Have a great night.
And I hope you have a Merry Christmas dreams.
And lots of Christmas cheer.
And lots of holiday festive cheer.
If you don't celebrate Christmas...
Lots of...
Just have a good time off.
A good day off.
Hopefully for you.
Thank you so much for the ping.
Thank you.
Otomito.
Bye bye.